I don't know if this is a me thing I'm
I'm going back to smell I'm like I maybe
I have been talking to melee for too
[__] long uh you definitely have yeah
because like okay you ever you ever met
like someone who smells like your
parents what the [__] yeah it's like the
least but that's a biological thing that
we've been programmed to not yeah cuz we
don't want to inbre yeah if you smell
like your parents you're like disgusted
by it yeah like I'm pretty sure there's
like a study that like your smell can
tell how close you are genetically to a
person CU like the L I just crush this
guy in
chest who asked the less in common you
have with their jeans the better they're
going to smell right
yeah I don't know I I don't know where
this came from oh this guy got F so does
so the the the million dollar question
is does Sydney smell good too Sydney
smells great which is great cuz that
means we cuz that mean this is going to
sound like the most serial killer
[__] talk cuz that means genetically
we we are we are very genetically
diverse but she smells like
[Music]
apples thank God you smell good God I
got to stop do to M you been doing m in
too
much I have I have I holy [__] that's uh
but that's that's like the trouble of
like long distance relationship because
I had like so many anxieties obviously I
was like very very excited to like meet
Syd but like there are this was like my
very first longdistance relationship so
there were just so many things that I
was used to in like an real like an in
not a real person like an uh close like
a close distance relationship that I'm
like there are so many gaps in my
knowledge that I would feel very very
comfortable about but approaching this
longdistance relationship I'm not I'm
like kind of just have to hope those
gaps that aren't filled are just like
good you know how how long were you in a
long distance with Sydney for was like a
year or something oh that's not even
that that bad yeah 2 and a half years
boy two and a half years how did you do
it man how did you do it well the way we
did it was we were both established
YouTubers at that point and so we could
work from
anywhere so there would be moments where
I'm just like yeah I'll be in Vegas for
3 months yeah sure I'll come and live
with you for 3 months and I did that
multiple times like I I think over my
entire life I probably spent over a year
and a half of my life in Vegas that's
why you [__] hate Vegas yeah that's
why I [__] hate Vegas
I've seen every corner of that place and
in conclusion it's a bit of a [__] hole
sorry Vegas fans but it's all coming out
now it's all coming out now like I would
not you would not you would not catch me
living there that's cuz you don't gamble
so no I don't I don't gamble I don't
really care about that whole there's a
couple like there's a couple of great
restaurants there that I'll [__] love
to go back to every time I go back to
Vegas but other than that it's just like
whatever you know I'd rather be some
else in the US yeah I mean I I think
Vegas was really really fun when we went
there on tour but I think that's just
because you're there with the boys
holiday yeah you know it's a completely
different experience we've talked about
Vegas in the daytime and that was like I
never knew a city could look so [__]
different yeah look who I beat oh you
beat Sasuke you beat Sasuke beat SAS
rating uh I thought your rating was
higher yeah I I've been well playing
after I've drank on the set and uh yeah
I I haven't played in ages and i' threw
a lot this is the most disorganized
trash this episode we're just talking
about long distance meanwhile our host
is playing CH I clap SASE after a bottle
and a half of wine
bro dog [__] BR of course you did I had
zero mistakes zero inaccuracy zero
blunders one great move thank you
chess.com thank you came second in the
chess special well by the time this is a
i' I I will have also wiped out of POG
Champs and lost miserably but at least I
had fun that's good do you think going
to do well for that we're going to age
this episode Fu [__] no I haven't played
chess in [__] forever what do you
mean you just played it but I'm playing
against sauno and Javis and I think
they're even worse
than that's easy W you know what their
ratings are I can't wait for this I
think shuno was 200 and Javis is like
you serious I think yeah and I think ja
actually I think Javis is pretty good I
think Javis like I think you were on
[__] jav's podcast weren't you yeah
that was on the I found out the other
day what do you mean you found out like
I hit it it just Rand it just randomly
found out didn't tell you well first of
all first of all uh I heard you went on
another
podcast on our podcast this is like this
is like when you're in a married
relationship for like 10 years and
you're like what were you doing around
that girl's house the other day let me
[__]
finish first of all two other boys
who first of all I want to apologize to
Jaris I didn't even know you had a
podcast second of all you didn't tell us
what do you mean I you didn't bring you
don't need to tell us everything I need
to know everything you're doing I do so
much [__] what do you mean I know tell
me everything you're doing you're on the
Javis podcast and I randomly found it
and I was like oh [__] he was on the
Javis podcast yeah jvis is uh Dov great
guys I like said like why didn't you
tell us we need we need to know
everything that you're doing I need to
what is your entire everything you're
doing give me your schedule right now I
need to know everything you're doing uh
hold
on what you starting up another chess
game I'm just won yeah um I remember I
was uh so I met I met Javis at um jvis
Jordan at chess boxing yeah and Javis
who i' obviously I've seen his videos
before yeah I I didn't know if you know
because with a Creator you never want to
wow with a Creator you never want to
assume they they know of you it's kind
of it's weird it's kind of weird if you
do and then they don't and so you just
assume they have no idea who you are
which is a good way of doing it and you
talk to them like a nor human being but
I knew of jvis and and Jordan cuz i'
watched their stuff for I thought they
were very funny um and I speaking to
jvis and jvis just started geeking out
in this Irish bar in LA about even Gan
to me and I was like dude I know two
guys who would love to be here right now
but not me I don't give a [__] about
when are we getting jvis on the podcast
when jvis come to Japan bro really nice
guy and then Jordan who I'd also seen
from the videos who I met that night as
well and I was like Jordan where the
[__] are you from in the UK cuz you
sound so Posh uh and he was like I'm
from yada yada yada area I was like yeah
you [__] Posh boy uh and he sound so
spoken I'm so jealous I wish I wish I
sounded as onen as eloquent as he does
and they're both so funny uh they're
really nice guys as well and he was
making bomb lates he was making the
whole latte art by himself in his house
was crazy he went hard I I I let the
machine do it there's no artwork it's
just it pours but I like that though I
don't need I don't need artwork and I'm
but it was nice that someone else made
the artwork for me what kind of kind of
artwork was it he's doing the classic
the like the plant thing that everyone
does with oh the
leaf but hey not to knock him down he's
still doing I don't do that [__] that's
sh hard as [__] I've tried doing it and
I've [__] failed at it yeah I mean
that's why people get paid for that [__]
grinding his own beans pressing his own
bees with the things I was like it was
like it was it was amazing watching him
do it hell yeah you know I ruined like
my previous apartment because of the
coffee machine we got like we got like
an espresso machine this was before like
the espresso we like let's tried getting
an espresso machine uhhuh and I was just
like is it espresso uh yes espresso
espresso I I can't stop saying expresso
why do you say espresso I don't know
what happened to NE child cuz he's fast
as [__] boy I was expresso I was maybe
dropped on the head I'm I'm joking I'm
joking actually a mug training actually
that's when I started like anime
actually
no it was a coin flip it was a coin flip
became a brain I you said that not me
um what was I trying to say yeah is
either the Dragon Ball fan or an anime
fan yeah um we bought like CH the right
choice we bought an espresso machine uh
like uh the cheapest one we could find
which obviously had no automation to it
as well so you needed to know what you
were doing I mean I think there's
benefits to it not being automated yeah
there's a lot of I'm just lazy and I
don't want to deal with it I'm sure
there is um but I learned what those
benefits were uh when I tried to make my
first experim ESO uh and espresso
espresso also we Gast at you one time
you said P pers P Pate or something yeah
I found out it's a real word you right
wrong sorry I guessed that you D yeah
basically like I tried make making my
first and then I you know I was like
okay I can follow the YouTube tutorial
put it in and I thought I locked it
didn't properly lock so what I get was
high press coffee beans spewing [__]
everywhere at high temperature and it
stained my White Walls like for like
ever and I'm like I should not be
allowed near this thing that's [__]
hilarious did you watch this YouTube
video did you watch uh this's a YouTuber
Guy what's it called James Hoffman the
guy who like talks in a very it's so the
coffee beans I know that name actually
you know there's the correct amount of
grams to have in your coffee cup before
you I meant to put it I love watching
him because he talks about coffee like
it's a science it's very impressive I
imagine it's like Tom Scott if he got
into coffee um is very interesting and I
I like to think that I care when I watch
but I I really don't I like the machine
and I press the one button but I I
appreciate that he cares a lot about it
and that there is a difference I just
don't know yeah he must drink an ungodly
amount of coffee I wish I was him
discuss nothing to
discuss about a good a good invigorating
topic before we change wa I I cannot
remember what we were talking about we
were talking about online relationships
oh yeah yeah and we just finished about
Joey what about you guys you about
yourself I I did talk about myself okay
I was I was yeah talking about how it's
become outdated what about you have you
ever been a long distance uh have I ever
been long yeah I have when I was like 18
okay yeah out like did it end before you
IRL I [__] didn't cuz I was 18 I had
no goddamn money and I couldn't how did
you her uh voice acting oh [__] okay
yeah and it didn't work out well uh and
so uh I was like h I'm over this doing
this long distance thing uh so I was
over it if I can't smell you it's game
over game no game so I but then I uh I
had like uh how many listes I have with
that one I had a few and then like one
of them I did Show online and I pretty
much was like what's the [__] point of
showing this online I was like I got
there's no point of talking about it or
whatever cuz it when we broke up people
were like oh you still with that person
I was like no no I'm not m why did I why
did I put myself in a situation where I
could even be put in the they didn't
even need to know anyway why do I care
if some [__] Steve 81 cares if I'm in
a relationship and all I don't give a
[__] this must be
before how did you guys know I was
dating Sydney what do you mean I was
pretty [__] obvious wait what the
[__] what do you mean no like what you
sound like a paranoia guy
like okay I'm I'm I'm a bit I'm a bit
drunk uh I'm trying to I'm trying to
remember when when I found out about you
yeah and this was roughly around the
time where you hit me up it was like a
little bit before then that I looked
into you and then I saw that you were
going out with this girl called Sydney
and I was just like Oh okay that's cool
like how did you know that was it a Wiki
or what the [__] I actually don't know
how I knew yeah yeah I'm I'm trying to
think and I'm like how when did you
first announce or public never announced
it yeah how okay yeah now now now this
now this is Bing me how did I know you
were going out
Sy I I met you
both you both you knew we were dating
beforehand right yeah how F I don't
[__] know how I knew no actually I
think the day I found out was the day we
met up IRL oh it cuz Sydney came along
yes she did and then we went to the
zakaya and karaoke no you you you need
to have known that because I that like I
tweeted you being like hey like I get
that you're in a longdistance
relationship I can Rel I was also in a
long relationship you must have already
knew that before because you replied to
Sydney's tweet as well hold on I hate to
interrupt but our host just left that
doesn't matter right now oh you going no
no no I I think I I think I found out
because of when we were having that DM
interaction of like you saying like hey
me you must have said something along
the Lin like me and my partner in Japan
right now or something along those lines
and so I was like oh okay you have a
partner and then
when we met IRL and then I met Sydney
and I was just like oh okay that this
must be your partner and then it was
just kind of natural like I think there
was a part of me where I was like this
guy can't be
single he's got too much
Riz all right genuinely anyone who's
watching this please answer my question
for me because I genuinely don't know
when it became public that like made the
[__] up
that me like like I generally don't know
when it happened or how must have
mentioned it in the DM conversation we
had before met I feel like I just knew
before I met you though I just knew I
just cuz like I never like I was
thinking about it when hearing your
story I was like I've never made an
official announcement that hey me and
Sid snap are dating um well that's
because at that point Sid snap wasn't
even like fully established at that
point right like she had made a couple
of videos sure but like she kind of took
like a big break in between right yeah I
mean she did a lot of voice iting and a
lot of like online communties that's how
she like made her name and that's like
how we met as well but like I I can't
remember an ever a point where we kind
of just announced that we were dating or
anything and kind of came natur like
thinking back I'm like oh everyone just
knows just like everyone knew and there
was not a point where people didn't know
to be fair that's probably the easiest
coming from someone who had to make a
whole [__] video around it to being
like by the way if you didn't catch all
the signs I dating
like and there were a lot of people I
remember when I released that video that
were just like no [__] way cuz I
guess there's some people who weren't
invested in yeah like you know you know
like on YouTube analytics there's like
the whole thing of like what percentage
of males versus what percentage of
females talked about this yeah like
before I came out about Ary or before
Ary and I even like met each other when
we were still in a long distance I
remember I think like my split was like
50/50 perfectly it was like 50% male 50%
female the moment I for talking about a
[__] anime yeah I was shocked I was
like who are these 50% female and then
after I came out you sound like you want
to find them who are they who are they
they don't exist tell me where they are
but women who love anime don't exist and
then the moment I came out what about
Ary I think it dropped to like
8020 which in which way male to
female like my female audience just was
just like all right I'm done and then
just [__] left and then all the dudes
were like my man let's go and then it's
been 8020 ever since so do you have
shout out to the 20% women